children
yes Salem we're back
the Sanderson sisters have flown back to
our screens with Disney Plus's
long-awaited sequel to Hocus Pocus
[Music]
and now that it's streaming fans are
wondering if a third installment is in
the works the right script was presented
and and the women were into it I mean we
gotta we would have to do it quick I
think a brief scene after the end
credits reveals that on the Shelf of the
magic shop there is yet another black
flame candle leaving the door open for
Hocus Pocus 3.
foreign
and while nothing is official yet the
film screenwriter says they're playing
with some ideas
I mean there are ideas there's lots of
ideas oh yeah I mean as soon as I
started thinking about like okay what
would this equal be it instantly it was
like okay and you could also tell this
story and this story and this story like
the characters are just so fun and so
iconic I feel like you can do so much
with them do you think Kathy SJP and Pat
would be on board I mean I hope so we
got him back again I feel like we can
try her a third time we'll just have to
wait and see if Sarah Jessica Parker
Kathy and Jimmy and Bette Midler are
down but the rest of the cast they're
totally in if there's a script for a
third one are you in because I think the
possibilities there just saying yes but
don't tell anybody are you kidding
it would be a dream like yes yes a
million times yeah I mean I'm there
there's the third one I'm there of
course noticeably absent from Hocus
Pocus 2 Thora Birch who played Danny in
the OG flick
I thought that would never come sisters
greetings little word
ET chatted with the actress ahead of the
sequel's release and she explained why
she couldn't fly into Salem for part two
we were really hoping for uh for a Max
for a Danny Cameo were you ever in talks
or were you ever approached to be a part
yeah there were three options we had for
how to bring Danny back and all of which
I was excited by but as it turns out by
the time they finally got around to
filming I was already on something else
what happened
a virgin
lit the candle hey if there's a maybe a
Hocus Pocus three I'm open-minded you
want to talk spin-offs you want to talk
at all of it let's go I love it I mean
where is Danny today that's the question
that's the question okay so that was
maybe something
yeah that's kind of what we were gonna
explore
[Music]